so um today we're talking about the one
that got away or the one actually we'll
start with the one so tell me do you
guys believe in the in the one and tell
me why yes or no
you know what yeah yes I know
I'm a little bit I won't lie to you so
like I'll have the one for like a month
and then I'll be like he's not even all
that like my moving like this so yeah
yeah
I believe there's the one out there
I feel like obviously time is just the
essence so I feel like there's a
different time for everyone my best
friends Nan and Granddad have been
together for 58 years
me I'm Single Living my best life till
forever notice but when it comes it
comes but I do believe it will come
I don't believe there's the one because
I think you could have multiple ones
so I feel like yeah I don't think
there's just one significant person so I
feel like in your lifetime you can have
more than one the one so now how many
your ones have you had
so
you meet that person that um ticks with
the boxes and then you just say yep
you're good to go
yeah
um I tend to agree with him I think you
choose the one because um
I mean like especially in this day and
age it's too much like we've got too
much choice and um
we can kind of like siphon out what we
want what we don't want you know we've
most of us have been around the block
enough to know like what we will
tolerate and not tolerate so yeah
easy you're in the black big dog
what's that been around the block yeah
no no he said like he's tired
um
you know I'm not gonna be different I
believe in that there's the one
that one person there
even if there was a good person in your
life like 20 years ago
even if you're with a man or woman now
that person if I say the one that person
from way back when it sticks in your
brain [__] that's the one I believe
there's one for everyone mm-hmm and it's
lucky that I got my one I left my one I
got my one I'm with my one and how is
there a one for everyone if there's 55
if there's more women than men on the
planet it's 55 women 45 men maybe some
of them double up in it hang on a minute
look how many ones she had yeah I just
said I've got one she said she had
multiple ones I mean she's not good not
at the same time
yeah I mean we were talking about the
one and she was like yeah there's the
one this time I want that time one yeah
we're talking about V1 yeah she's got
five D ones right yeah it wouldn't be
the one it's not the one
exactly but we were saying the one that
she had multiple you said you said you
believe in the one you think there's
something I do I believe that how is how
is there someone for everyone if there's
more women on the planet than men if
there's more women in plant than men
that means that some people got more
than one ones or they got the same one
some girls have to share yes
but you don't know you might not know
I don't jump from a relationship I don't
jump from man I will know when it's the
right time I'm not talking about you
jumping from my man I'm talking about
you having the same man for about 10
years he could be your one and then you
find that there's another woman that's
been out there 15 years and she is also
yeah so who's his woman that means
there's not one for everyone I mean it's
kind of different to women some people
just miss out well you don't you don't
think like is that a term we hear more
for women or for men yeah but that's
what I'm saying women say like he's the
one but you don't hear men say that
because men are nasty they just want to
ski you think most men are nasty woman
women
say all men are nasty is be a lesbian
that's what I'm saying
now if you're not a lesbian you can't
sit here and turn around and say that
all men are saying that all the men and
that you've had a nasty yeah I don't
believe the old man a nasty
yeah
lesbians
that means that she's going to have
nasty men no that's that means she's
gonna have now see me
she can't turn around here and sit down
and say that all men are nasty and
expect to have a man if you're gonna
turn around and say that old men are
nasty expect to have a woman because
that means that you don't want a man
because that man's gonna be nasty so as
you're gonna say that the minute she's
dealing with are nasty oh so many nasty
but I'm gonna sit here and let a woman
Jesus
you know what you gotta say that because
that means that he's nasty he's nasty
he's nasty he's nasty because
I have so many friends that have told me
their experiences we all have similar
experiences Echo Chambers
I'll tell you the numbers behind it one
out of three men under 30 are their
virgins or haven't had sex in the last
year most women are sexually active
women are more nasty than men by and
large just because it's because it's
because it's because women only select a
very small percentage of men on dating
apps we only swipe right five percent of
the time so the reason you think men are
trash is because you're all sleeping
with the same ones so like you said
about have you said anything
so I never said nastiness is just about
no I'm not nothing it's a quality it's
not subscribers describe it what do you
mean by nasty
right now I think humans are neatly
selfish and that's what I'll say and
that's what I mean by not all humans
no no no no no no no no no
I don't admits
guys guys one at a time
for me personally I feel like you can
have more than one soul mate in life
yeah but there's always the one like
there's always the one you can have more
than one soul mate but there's always
the one there's no plural there's always
like the one or maybe not always but if
you find the one there's just that one
and you will know when you leave her in
it yeah when she's gone in 10 years
later you can find another soul mate
though but you never remember the one no
there's a difference there's a
difference
you're cool if you're saying to someone
they're your soul mate that's like you
can get deeper than soulmate you can you
can see
you can go into twin flame you could get
deeper and saw me trust me
you could get deeper than something
trust me look it up there's always the
one like whether she's in your life or
out your life even for women as well
like whether they're in your life
there's always that one
nah that's not yeah
okay what do you think so my my thing is
here I believe there's the one in it and
I'm gonna know when I get that one
because that one is gonna stop me from D
my dog and [__] and I want to get there
because I love I love loving it you know
what I mean but at the moment I'm just
living but there is the one in it you
know what I'm saying but I'm just saying
something as well like what's her name
sorry what's your name man yeah Sharon
you need to slow down with calling every
man to stink back because I know
somebody I know that's a stink bug in it
I know some good [__] out there I know
some men that would die for the yellow
well there's an end because you're young
you're young and you're stupid yeah
you're young and you're still you're
still messing with the little [__]
them that's that's trying to run around
and beat you in your bedroom at the same
time which you're saying there's nothing
wrong with that man just trying to get
there but you see the thing is that what
what you like you you know sorry I I say
this all the time in it a lot of women
got this whole thing where they think
they've been watching Disney movies and
think that's life that's relationship
that's not religion I ain't just women
that think that there's some men as well
I'm I'm a man I don't think like that
but okay we said somewhere but in order
to have a conversation we have to make
generalities and and who watches Disney
movies women or men yeah but then you're
getting that house so generalizing
saying that Madness
because because by and large men because
by and large men aren't nasty by and
largely statistically there's no piece
of data that you can find out there that
says by and large men are nasty but he
didn't he didn't he didn't generalize
she said all
right
he didn't say oh when he's talking about
Disney he didn't say oh she said oh man
so out of the men and the women
I don't hear the men they waiting for
their princess to come I'm always
hearing women talking about how many
frogs I have to kiss before I reach the
prince I never hear a man saying that
okay
no what we're trying to say is that
Disney don't work for men so when
they're saying about the women that gay
man you're talking about because I had
no man saying oh I'm waiting for my
princess to come okay
for the queen queen ain't got nothing to
do with Disneyland
let me speak if you ask a black man yeah
a bad Queen got nothing to do with
Disney yeah nothing to do with Disney
and if you ask a black woman about her
please
oh whenever this Frog's gonna come it's
always something to do with Disney but
you will never ever hear a black man say
that he wants a queen and an empress and
to do with Disney it's always tribals no
but you don't understand where it comes
comes from it don't come from Disney it
comes from the ancestor it comes from
Africa and that's what I'm talking about
when they when he's talking about the
girls and their Disney they're waiting
for their prince to come and then they
turn around like the women normally do
it say oh what about the men the men's
doing it they call it a queen queen and
Disney come totally different in Disney
you got princess but you've never heard
you never hear a man talk about Princess
you always hear a man talk about his
Queen his Queen hang on a minute
actually
right when you're hearing talking about
his Queen ain't got nothing to do with
Disney but you can't say nothing they're
talking about yeah
talk about his Queen it's his black
queen everyone talk about this princess
it's his black princess and it comes
from Africa don't cover nothing to do
with Disney and that somebody said
they've got Rastafarians in go and ask
your part father and he's talking about
his Queen if he mentions Disney
exactly but so when the men are talking
about Queen don't confuse it with Disney
she's talking about a prince will come
he's never heard that though listen
though you're talking about Disney he
said where you're coming from is Disney
she's bringing up the queen a queen for
a black person has nothing to do with
Disney if he's putting the woman there
he's one of the woman dead that's his
Queen that's his Emperor this is a
carry-on on his chest Disney man not
carried out there with a horse to carry
you they'll carry over the shoulder on
what the [__] seven doors
sorry so for me I've got a queen in the
queen is the person that gave birth to
me in it my Empress is going to be
together you know what I'm saying yeah
that's nice
but you guys are watching too much
Disney thing I think that's like as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible